madame monsieur bonjour commençons par
un mauvais jeu de mots un événement qui
fait froid dans le dos cet événement ne
s'est pas passé sous nos yeux mais il a
bien eu lieu en antarctique un bloc de
glace de la taille du luxembourg 3200
kilomètres carrés 720 milliards de
tonnes de glace viennent de se détacher
sous l'effet du réchauffement climatique
de la planète
le dernier événement en date de cette
envergure remontait à 30 ans et 7 un
demi-degré seulement de plus qui est la
cause de cette rupture
quelles conséquences sur le niveau des
océans explications patrice plaie des
atrides murnau c'est un pays qui est à
la dérive
un pays grand comme le luxembourg cette
plaque à plus de 3000 km carrés et
contient 720 milliards de tonnes de
glace
la dislocation a commencé le 31 janvier
dernier sans aucun problème
les 220 mètres d'épaisseur du glacier
ont été tronçonnés comme lorsqu'on
combine un gâteau avec un couteau
larsen b que l'on voit ici sur cette
photo satellite est donc à la dérive et
fond c'est le réchauffement de notre
planète qui serait responsable et nomen
que l'on observe aussi très bien de
l'autre côté au pôle nord ici la
température augmente graduellement
là encore la glace fond se transforme en
rivière et provoque le détachement des
blocs le sol est perturbée car le
permafrost est exposé au soleil à la
chaleur au vent il ya davantage de pluie
les étés sont plus haut et les printemps
apparaissent plus tôt je ne sais pas
stupéfaction dans la communauté
scientifique
il n'aura fallu que trente cinq jours
pour que la plaque se détache et la zone
larsen b a déjà perdu 40% de sa surface
en cinq ans un phénomène que les
spécialistes surveillent depuis
plusieurs années
le lien entre la fonte de ces plaques de
glace et le réchauffement climatique
mais on ne sait pas pourquoi les
opérateurs augmentent
ni même pourquoi et cela a été aussi un
drame intime questions préoccupantes ce
glaçons géant peut-il vraiment faire
monter le niveau des océans
d'après les spécialistes rien à craindre
pour le moment alors sur le garçon aura
fondu et bien le volume total d'eau
n'aura pas changé on aura exactement le
même niveau d'eau et c'est ce qui se
passe en fait dans l'océan lorsque ces
sas vers ces plateformes de glace vont
fondre dans l'océan dans plusieurs
siècles ces ours blancs pourront ils
encore se promener sur ces étendues
glacées
à l'heure actuelle personne ne peut
encore l'affirmer
tous les scénarios sont envisageables la
terre est fragile
notre avenir ne dépend que de nous